Пане Габек, Ваш візит в Україну почався із зустрічі з президентом України Володимиром Зеленським
та міністром закордонних справ Дмитром Кулебою, з яким ви обговорювали постачання зброї в Україну.
Наскільки зміцнилась ваша позиція в цьому питанні після відвідин Донбасу?
Моя поїздка на Донбас, на лінію зіткнення, була вражаючою, а також тривожною.
Хоча я ще до цього зайняв позицію, що необхідно підтримувати українську армію
та захищати життя солдатів й передусім цивільного населення,
а Німеччина повинна зробити у це свій внесок.
Мій візит на лінію зіткнення лише конкретизував певні речі.
Наприклад, мені показали, як скидають з маленьких безпілотників міни,
як здійснюють атаки снайпери. Це все конкретизує позицію.
Але я й до цього вважав, що треба зокрема переглянути постійне принципове "ні" уряду Німеччини,
коли йдеться про поставки матеріалу, який може захистити життя людей.
Чи має змінитись формат Мінська після інциденту із посадкою пасажирського літака
і арешту журналіста в Білорусі?
Мінський формат - найкраще, що у нас є. Треба зробити спроби оживити як Нормандський формат,
так і Мінські угоди. Адже, якщо бути чесними, наразі немає жодного дипломатичного поступу.
Я бачу зусилля багатьох сторін, зокрема й України, досягти там прогресу.
Водночас я бачу, що усі спроби знайти рішення, наприклад, в питанні обміну полоненими,
а це невеликі кроки, які потрібно зробити,  в даний момент заморожені і немає руху вперед.
А з іншого боку я бачу розгортання військ росіян у квітні, я бачу перехоплення літака над Білоруссю,
яке, безсумнівно, відбулось не проти волі Росії.
А тепер ще й перешкоджання німецьким інституціям у Росії у справі підтримки громадянського суспільства.
Усе це не дуже обнадійливі сигнали. Тож нам потрібен новий підхід.
І його появі могла б сприяти зупинка будівництва "Північного потоку-2".
Я не маю на увазі, що треба сідати і обговорювати це просто завтра о 15 годині.
Натомість варто ще раз обдумати і знову висунути конфлікт на порядок денний,
що обмізкувати, як його вирішити. Енергія, яка була в Мінську,
поступилася місцем певному розчаруванню, й існують різні способи подолання цього розчарування.
Одним із способів може бути посилення програми наставництва ОБСЄ,
розширення мандату ОБСЄ. Наприклад, забезпечити чи розширити доступ до територій,
підконтрольних сепаратистам, чи тих, куди ОБСЄ наразі потрапити не може.
Також посилити дипломатичний тиск на Москву, наприклад, через "Північний потік-2".
Ще одне питання про "Північний потік-2".
Чи можлива ситуація, що після парламентських виборів у Німеччині проєкт буде зупинено?
Для мене важливо, щоб "Північний потік-2" не був завершений. Це головне і найважливіше.
Якщо будівництво таки завершать, необхідно з’ясувати юридичні питання щодо того,
чи можна вводити газопровід в дію.
З моєї точки зору, третій енергетичний пакет ЄС цього не дозволяє.
І якщо це так, то ситуацію потрібно вирішувати. Але ми ще не на цьому етапі.
В Україні також є "Партія Зелених" і вона одна з найстаріших у країні, але в парламенті була лише раз.
Як думаєте, чому в Україні така низька підтримка політики зелених?
Наша партія Зелених, як і практично в кожній країні Європи,
виникла на хвилі протестного руху 70-их та 80-их років.
Це був рух громадськості  проти забруднення довкілля, за мир.
Можливо, щось подібне відбувається зараз в країнах Східної Європи.
Проблеми є, і якщо ви знову задасте мені це питання через 20-30 років,
якщо я тоді взагалі ще даватиму інтерв’ю, я впевнений, що зможу дати іншу відповідь.
На сході України, в Маріуполі, де я був, чаділи димарі.
Мені сказали, що ситуація вже покращилася порівняно з п’ятьма роками тому.
Мабуть, так і є. Але, звичайно, це не той хороший екологічний стан,
який сьогодні може мати сталеливарний завод.
Ми багато говорили з екологічними групами, а також з оператором металургійного комбінату про те,
як можуть виглядати наступні інвестиційні кроки задля охорони довкілля.
І вони мають велику програму та вкладають туди чималі кошти.
Я сподіваюся, що ці гроші будуть використовуватись ефективно,
а не осідатимуть в кишенях якихось менеджерів,
примножуючи їхні статки замість захисту довкілля.